people do debt consolidation and they
take five or six cards a medical bill
whatever bill these handful of bills
they got laying around and they go get a
second mortgage on their house or they
go get a little unsecured loan at the
credit union and they do debt
consolidation or worse than that they go
down to one of these ripoff financed
storefront places and they do debt
consolidation and pay twenty six percent
interest
so we consolidated a bunch of eight nine
ten percent interest rates to twenty six
to start with that would be
mathematically stupid but at least
they'll just got one payment and that's
our brains work right and so here's the
problem though that doesn't get you out
of that you just moved it you cannot
borrow your way out of that here's the
numbers eighty-eight percent of the
people that do debt consolidation
continue in the negative habit pattern
of overspending not having a budget and
they go further into debt because they
don't change their habits and they feel
like oh I took care of that debt and you
know how I know you feel that way is
because out of the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks the Bible says
and we say things like oh I paid off my
debt with a debt consolidation loan no
you didn't you doober you moved your
debt you didn't pay off anything you
just moved it but here but the fact that
you say I paid off might say that tells
you that you felt like you did something
now Laura's not in that category so a
whole different thing but this
discussion I'm having now resides in the
same place in your brain that trem
balance transfers on the credit card to
zero interest level it feels like you
did something and you didn't no big deal
whoopee the secret sauce is changing the
person on your mirror and you go that's
it I was a child before I thought like a
child I walked like a child and acted
like a child I'm not child anymore and
now
gonna be a grown freaking person and I
am going to actually address these
issues now that you could be 62 when
you're saying that you could be 19 when
you're saying that I don't care it's not
a chronological thing
it's an emotional maturity thing adults
devise a plan and follow it children do
what feels good personal finances 80%
behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
you cannot do what feels good with money
and be anything but broke because you're
a child one definitely one way we know
you're mature one definition of
emotional maturity is the ability to
delay pleasure no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness the ability to
delay pleasure for a greater good is the
sign that you have become my child a
grown-up and I meet 57 year olds who
cannot make a decision to delay pleasure
and so there's still a child an old
wrinkled child but there's still a child
I'm 58 so shut up okay so but I mean
really I can and sometimes I'm still
that way a little not with money stuff
but were those stuff but the ability to
delay pleasure for a greater good the
ability to delay pleasure for a greater
good adults devise a plan and follow it
no farmer walks out to the field and
looks at the dirt and says where's my
corn farmers are grownups
they understand cause and effect they
understand that what you plant you will
reap you will reap what you sow what you
plants what's going to come out of the
ground when they plant corn they don't
walk out there and go where's my beans
they understand cause and effect when
they plant corn they don't walk out
there and go why is this corn puny when
they didn't put any fertilizer on it
they know it's got to be fertilized and
they don't walk out there and look at
their field full of weeds and wonder why
it did not yield a bumper crop they know
they have to kill the weeds you have to
till
crop is work and and you know and you
know they take a blank dirt field and
scratch rows in it with a tractor and a
plow and put little seeds in the ground
all with the expectation that sometime
next year I'm gonna make some money off
of that see that's the ability to delay
pleasure they're doing work today that
they don't benefit from today they'd
benefit later that's emotional maturity
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good you know the
fact that we used to be in an agrarian
culture in the US and that most people
grew up on the farm at least is no
longer true is hurting us because we
don't have the ability to look into the
future and have vision anymore